training outdoors has a ton of amazing
advantages and in my recent video
discussing how the environment shapes
you an implicit argument was that
training outside and in the wild was
often better than training in a plush
gym or at home because you have that
more chaotic nature but some commenters
politely pointed out that there were
issues with training outside all the
time they discussed how you can't
measure progressive overload in the same
way they talked about maybe how they
don't have access to a nice park and a
lot of people were just asking how do
you program something like this at all
so in this video i thought i'd talk you
through how you can train outdoors and
how you can incorporate this kind of
more wild training into your normal
routine we're gonna train like tarzan
let's go
so first let's talk about why you should
train outside and why being brought up
in the wild like tarzan really could
result in some phenomenal performance
and the simple way to think about this
is that the body craves complexity i'm
talking about chaos i'm talking about
variability if you're constantly
training in the same condition in the
same environments then you're going to
find that you ultimately hit a kind of
plateau so every time you pick up a
barbell in a gym it's the exact same
movement pattern you're lifting a
straight smooth bar off of a straight
flat ground conversely if you pick up a
heavy log for example now it's a grip
challenge so you have to try and grip on
to the bark and prevent it from slipping
out your hand at the same time it
becomes a stability challenge for your
shoulders because the weight isn't going
to be evenly distributed you're going to
find that it rocks more to one side and
that's also going to engage your
obliques and your hips and your
multifidus and when you've finished
pressing a log you can just launch it as
far as you like which is pretty cool and
it builds ballistic strength if you do
that in the gym with a barbell what i
find is you get kicked out and according
to nikolai bernstein this can help to
develop more robust motor patterns that
then translate better to the real world
because when you move something in the
real world it's not going to be barbell
shaped
there's a fine line to be walked here
because something like a push-up on a
ring is so much more likely to lead to a
wrist injury or to crush your fingers
but imagine that once you've built up
that amount of strength and control how
much less likely you are to injure your
wrist in other exercises that require
that amount of risk control
this is just a much more sensory rich
experience this is about not only
exerting strength but exerting strength
in the correct way for your environment
it's about responding to the visual
motor landscape which is what you need
to be able to do if you're in a real
setting you're training your nervous
system to become more agile more stable
and better able to react to what's going
on around it this is also what brings
the brain to life if you repeat the same
movement over and over again it becomes
a rote you don't need to focus however
if you train in a novel an exciting way
something that maybe has a small element
of risk and we do need to be very
careful doing this kind of stuff then
you're going to wake up the brain you're
going to trigger those dopamine systems
and plasticity is going to kick in in a
big way this is just a far more engaging
way to train and by the same token it's
much more fun and exciting
finally this provides the kind of
balance and the kind of complexity that
training program needs to prevent
overlooking certain muscle groups that
could lead to imbalances and later on
issues with movement for example running
on a flat surface can often lead to
issues with it band pain because you're
running in a straight line all the time
you're never dodging from side to side
leading to tightness trail running on
the other hand especially in barefoot or
minimal shoes is going to help you to
develop the kind of stability you need
in the legs and the hips to prevent that
sort of pain and to prevent knee pain
help your knee track more easily as i've
talked about in the past there are too
many small muscle groups too many areas
we can easily overlook if we train with
just a few movement patterns but by
using the kind of variety and complexity
and unpredictability that the
environment provides us with then we can
make sure that we naturally cover all of
these bases and it's no surprise that
the natural environment does all this
because that's the environment that we
evolved in that's the environment that
shaped us so it's not so much the case
that the environment happens to be just
right for us it's more the case that we
happen to be just right for the
environment
so that's enough about why you should go
and train outside and in the wild the
next question is how do you go about
doing it and i think i'll start with the
first and biggest objection i often hear
which is that it doesn't allow for
progressive overload if you're picking
up logs and rocks each time you pick
them up they're going to be a different
weight but for starters this doesn't
need to be your only form of training
that's not what i'm about at all in fact
my whole shtick is that you should
combine different training modalities
that includes this more than that
inspired type stuff alongside other
forms like bodybuilding like
powerlifting so if you're doing this on
the side you can view it just as
accessory work that's going to
strengthen you a little bit more outside
of that strict range of motion and
thereby improve your strength and your
lifts overall so i'm trying to learn the
ring muscle up at the moment i've never
actually had the opportunity to learn it
before because my pull-up bar is too low
but i've recently been really sold on
its merits so i thought it'd be a cool
skill to add to my arsenal
however it's much harder here on the
street branch because it's impossible to
get those rings to be not only the exact
same height but also to stay in the same
position as i'm transitioning through
the movement and that adds that whole
extra challenge of course i probably
would like to take this back to a
straight bar and practice and refine
movement there but then going to a
situation like this is going to help to
make that movement far more
robust once i've got it
so i'm going to say something that
sounds a little bit sacrilegious on
youtube fitness right now which is that
don't worry so much about progressive
overload do you need progressive
overload to improve absolutely making
your training harder is literally the
only way you can get stronger but this
doesn't mean you need to be really anal
tracking your numbers on every single
lift because here's the thing if you go
to the woods and you lift up a pretty
heavy log and the most you can do is 10
repetitions before you need to put it
down because you notice that your form
is starting to suffer
then what you've done there is you've
trained to your maximum rate of
perceived exertion or your maximum safe
rpe and then if you go to the woods and
you do the same thing the next day and
the next day and the next day eventually
when you come back to that initial log
you'll find that you can maybe do 11
reps in other words if you're training
as hard as you can every single time and
if you're just listening to your own
body then you'll naturally get better at
lifting up logs or whatever else it is
if you take a calisthenics approach to
things and if you focus more on being
able to unlock certain skills and moves
then you can use progressions in your
exercises
instead of increasing the amount of
weight so for instance if you want to be
able to do a front lever or a planche
then doing it out in the wild on uneven
terrain it's going to add a little bit
of extra challenge but you'll still
follow the exact same progressive
structure in your training you'll still
go from pseudo-planche push-up to tuck
planches to straddle planches to full
planche
and the variation in the tree branch
might mean that you don't progress quite
as linearly there will be days where you
can't do as many pull-ups as the day
before but this isn't actually the end
of the world you're still going to be
trending upwards and you're also filling
in those little gaps along the way that
you can't necessarily measure we
shouldn't be so fixated on numbers or of
course you can keep going back to the
same spot use the same log the same
branch and then you can literally see
yourself progress and get better at
those things however that's kind of
missing the point next issue that a lot
of you have brought up when it comes to
training outside and in a more wild
environment is that you just don't have
access to something like this and
therefore you can't train this way many
people comment saying like where do you
live man it's beautiful etc etc and
yeah i am very fortunate to have stuff
like this near me however let's be real
it's not like paradise here this is a
really small nature reserve it takes
about five minutes to walk all the way
across it i found a kind of like
clearing in the woods where not too many
people pass through but i'm still
stopping all the time for people with
dogs they're checking out my rings etc
that's not a euphemism basically it's
not the perfect environment to be
training in but i'm just making do and
some people commented on my crawling
video and said that that was a beautiful
spot well that was actually just
literally a big patch of grass in a
housing estate next to a pond that's
always empty and covered in bugs i just
used clever camera angles to make it
look beautiful
i do live in oxfordshire and there are a
lot of really beautiful places around me
i drive to places like brill sometimes
to watlington and
i'm lucky that i've got that option but
there's still a 20 or 30 minute drive
and i make the trip more for the videos
rather than for the training
in the past i've trained literally on a
tree on the side of a road and there's
so much you can do with the tree as i
hope you're seeing so much you can do
with a log but if you don't have access
to even a tree you still don't need to
worry because you can train this way at
home even indoors just by choosing the
right equipment you just want to
simulate this kind of environment so
something like a sandbag is the perfect
example of that because a sandbag isn't
a straight bar that moves in a
predictable manner in fact it's even
less predictable than any other stuff
out here
the weight inside the bag shifts around
it's unaccommodating resistance so every
time you perform a snatch or a clean
it's going to be slightly different and
this is something i've talked about in
the past likewise you can train with
medicine balls you can climb ropes you
can put gymnastics rings on some bars
even at your gym so there's loads of
options even just tie a bed sheet around
a door and do some bodyweight rows you
just want to mix up the exact angle the
exact grip and keep doing new things and
incorporate that kind of training into
your main workouts and even with just
body weight if you want to experiment a
little bit more with crawls and with
various mobility movements a little bit
of movement training and maybe some
calisthenics that you haven't done
before some hand balancing all that
stuff will have the same effects as this
of making your workouts more engaging
for the nervous system waking up your
brain and building those supporting
muscles
if you guys want a training program that
involves a bit more complexity and chaos
and variability to build a more
comprehensive and performant physique
then you can check out my ebook and
training program super functional
training i'll put a link to that in
description down below and there's a
discount on right now whilst we're still
dealing with a pandemic alternatively if
you just want to learn about more
conventional functional training what
that means for the average joe or for an
athlete then you can check out my print
book functional training and beyond and
you get that from all good bookstores
but there'll be a link to that in the
description down below also so for
videos like this one i do a lot of stuff
that's pretty goofy that i think
hopefully looks cool and will translate
well on camera i don't necessarily
recommend that you do all the stuff i'm
doing
in this video because yeah it's a little
bit
out there and it creates the risk of
stuff like this happening
i suffer from my art what can i say but
when i would train like this for real
without the camera rolling what i'd
basically do is come to a spot like this
warm up do some big or more complex
movements at the start essentially that
might be something like a difficult
calisthenics movement like some hand
balancing or some front levers or some
attempts at muscle ups or i might do
some bigger lifts with some logs then i
might move on to some like cool stunts
that i make up on the spot that i think
look exciting or interesting and could
offer some benefits but without pushing
myself too hard i'm already fatigued at
this point so in that example that i
just made up here right now on the spot
i'm using my lats and my biceps to pull
myself towards the tree trunk which is
creating enough friction that i can
climb up it at the same time as a grip
challenge as i'm really gripping onto
the bark and i've got that added
incentive because if i fall there's like
a bed of stinging nettles down there
then at the same time i'm pushing
through my quadriceps and my calves to
drive myself up and of course it's a
balancing task and it's a quadripedal
movement so just made up right there
does loads of stuff and i challenge you
to find an exercise in the gym that
trains quite so many things especially
in a multi-sensory manner and then i'll
just finish with some endurance cardio
usually in the form of some closed chain
calisthenics things like push-ups
pull-ups that can do for a high number
of repetitions to burn some fat at the
end so i'm building strength building
control and balance
experimenting and enjoying myself at the
same time burning some fat and improving
my cardio capacity so that's how i would
structure a workout like this i don't
think you want too much structure by its
very nature you want to be open to
options but if you have a few ideas what
you want to achieve going in then yeah
there's no reason you can't get a
fantastic workout out in the wild
whoever you are wherever you live
i think and i hope you guys agree if you
have any more questions or objections
let me know in the comments below and
i'll do my best to respond to them
perhaps in a future video thank you so
much for watching this one guys i hope
you found it useful and interesting if
you did then please leave a like and
share around that helps me out immensely
you want to see more like this then
subscribe hit the bell button if you
want to be notified of future uploads
and yeah i'll see you on the next one
thanks for watching
and bye for now